hey i i named melvin gordon my go to the
week in the column this week and uh and
again look it was hard to see
uh and it was uh obviously a difficult
excruciating
goal line drive by the los angeles
chargers
but i keep wondering you know after he
fumbles and loses the game for the
charges of the goal line
why exactly did the chargers bring
melvin gordon back
and what exactly has he done since he's
been back the question is i don't know
and nothing
yeah it certainly was uh not a good look
for melvin gordon uh
you know especially when you do hold out
and all that but the the chargers stink
they can't run blocked they can't do
anything uh but yeah he was on my list
too so i'm not gonna fault you for that
pick certainly i'm gonna go with another
guy that had a similar circumstance to
what you're talking about peter derek
carr
that would be my go to the week he had a
chance this weekend to get in a shootout
with aaron rodgers and really go a long
way to instill confidence as head coach
that like hey look i'm the guy i'm your
guy look at me i'm i'm dueling it out
with number 12 up in green bay right now
because as i mentioned before the
raiders were never really stopped during
the game against green bay
and this was the turning point of the
game it's about to be 17-14 going in the
half it's second and goal
and the reach out and then of course the
touchback uh changed the game forever
because the next time that the oakland
raiders touched the ball instead of
14-10 it was 28-10 and not only that you
know but he throws the interception
later as the game's 35-17 it's still not
over they can still make it somewhat
competitive so he
i think is to go to the week one because
of that play but two because he had a
chance really i think to make john
gruden feel a lot more warm and cozy
about him in general
and i think it's going to be the exact
opposite we talked about that yesterday
i think derek carr doing that same
stupid move that he did two years ago
against the cowboys almost an identical
replica of what happened two years ago i
don't know how you keep that guy if
you're john gruden if he can't learn
from that mistake that huge mistake he
didn't learn from it he did it again
that's going to be something that i
think pushes john gruden away from derek
carr all right i got to go doug peterson
i love doug peterson he's got a super
bowl trophy but i'll tell you what he
his fingerprints are all over that 37-10
loss to the cowboys when he blurts out
we're going to win and then he
he declines to double down on it when
he's asked about his guarantee what
guarantee i didn't make a guarantee well
yes you did and it did enough to stir up
the cowboys they mostly kept their
mouths shut before the game but that is
what got the cowboys locked in and
focused and you heard it after the game
some of the things that ezekiel elliott
said using some of the words that chris
sims dabbles in all the time doug
peterson and you know hey these guys
don't have to do radio and i don't know
if the coaches get paid to do these
radio spots if it's part of the deal
that they do with the the station that
carries the games or whatever but you
have to be as careful in that setting as
you are in a press conference you make
that little nonchalant comment and the
next thing you know it haunts you all
week long and to get blown out the way
they did did not show up the way they
did after he guaranteed a win doug
peterson gets the goat horns yeah
mike i'm gonna go with andy dalton
nudging sam darnold uh for my first pick
in the second round um
and and you know andy dalton basically
you know with the bengals oh and six
they're ahead going into the fourth
quarter
uh and what he does basically is he
throws an interception and gets returned
for a touchdown by yannick and gawkway
throws three interceptions overall the
end of the dalton era it has to be in
cincinnati
and as i wrote on a totally different
topic
um i just feel sorry for burro herbert
or tagovaloa
because one of those guys
it certainly seems like it's going that
way and i'm with you peter the end of
the andy dalton era is here uh i'm i
wouldn't be even shocked if they just
see what maybe this ryan finley has who
they drafted in the fourth round's got
before the years ended but not good
against jacksonville i'm going to
chicago i'm going to matinegaville okay
that's that's the go to the week for me
you know coming off a bye week and an
underwhelming really bad look in london
where you lose to the oakland raiders
and like really was offense was
dominated against the oakland raiders i
mean it was the defense that kept them
in the game that day and special teams
well same thing this week once again bye
week i don't know what the hell the
bears offense is somebody please tell me
it just looks like hey i called this
play hey this this group get out here on
the field i want to call this play why i
don't know because i just i have it here
on a list i mean so i don't know what
their offense is you they truly are like
the no identity offense they can't run
the ball they can't pass vertex their
passing schemes are very uh average and
normal trubisky's not good i'm done
defending him so there's just issues
across the board there and of course i
gotta place that blame on the head coach
matt nagy who's also the play caller
yeah it really has fallen apart quickly
for the chicago bears when it looked a
couple of weeks ago like they were
turning it around or at least their
defense would be good enough to get them
through this stretch while their offense
finds its rhythm they've lost the last
two games and they are not looking good
all right i you know i was tempted to go
with sam darnold peter you mentioned him
i don't know that i can really call him
a goat though because i don't know what
do you expect against that patriots
defense it's just this is
five turnovers i mean he's being free
well then you can take him next round
i i'm gonna i'm gonna do something that
pains me
because i think russell wilson is one of
the best quarterbacks in the nfl and i
think that he was the number one mvp
candidate going into
this weekend but that throw that he made
that marcus peters intercepted and
returned for a touchdown i don't know
what that was and it was so
uncharacteristic for russell wilson i'm
willing to call it a blip on the radar
screen the performance overall on the
day was not good for russell wilson on a
day when he's going against lamar
jackson a guy who can do all the things
russell wilson can do and maybe then
some to lose at home by only the second
time during the russell wilson era by
more than one scorer i tell you
somebody's got to own that one
and if if russell wilson's going to get
the praise when things go incredibly
well on the rare occasions when it falls
apart you got to recognize that as well
and i still think he could win the mvp i
think he can turn it around i think he's
one of the top three quarterbacks in the
game but for sunday and he'll probably
admit it himself he has the goat horns
yeah that was a big play there's no
doubt i i hear you there sorry i didn't
mean to go go ahead peter i'm forgetting
my order that's all right you know what
i i really want to borrow a goat from a
future show
i i because i've got two guys who i
desperately want to hand the goat horns
to
uh and i almost almost want to pick joe
flacco because i've never heard a tv
analyst laugh
at the play of a quarterback the way
that troy aikman laughed at joe flacco
on thursday night it was embarrassing it
was totally totally embarrassing the way
flacco played and the way that offense
played and it just puts so much pressure
on everybody in the organization all
right i've talked myself into it
somebody else can have sam darnold i
can't believe that joe flacco played
that way and also
the way he played so
lackadaisical
so laconic oh my god and and could we
please have as aikman said and as as
buck said i guess it was him late in the
game can we please have some sense of
urgency when you're down 900 to nothing
to matt moore at home
i i mean joe flacco you've got to wear
the goat horns this week
yeah uh horrible look by flacco that
offense in general i mean you know it's
not like kansas city's the steel curtain
or anything like that on the defensive
side of the ball i certainly was
expecting more there and yeah i did get
a kick out of uh troy aikman chuckling
at that performance um i'm not gonna go
sam darnold either maybe we we spent two
segments on it all right so we know he's
goat worthy uh so i'm not saying that
either i'm going there we've goaded him
enough with the go with his bad play
last night i'm going to go up to buffalo
with fitz tragic okay it was fitz tragic
i mean it really was miami dolphins were
controlling the football game up 14 to
nine it's second and two second and 12
on the 12 yard line and
as much as fitz magic happens and he
makes some great things happen and i
respect the way he plays unfortunately
you know stupid interceptions and really
bad spots or something that happens a
lot when he plays as well and the second
and 12 up five and having a chance to go
up eight or maybe even go up 12
but to try to squeeze in a ball down at
the one yard line uh it just was not
worth the risk at that point especially
on a second down and the game was never
the same from that point on buffalo went
on a 98-yard drive scored a touchdown
and controlled the game really from that
point on so
i got to give him the goat award there
just because he's more experienced and
more knowledgeable to do that in that
situation
all right and i agree with you there
that would have been one of my picks
potentially but you have allowed me to
do something that i don't think we've
ever done or may ever do again i am
giving the goat of the week to an entire
stadium and that is fedex field and i
know the pictures looked great and it
was old school football but in this day
and age it should never look like that
it should never be that sloppy muddy
mess this is an era where every field
should be perfect no matter how hard
it's raining and if you're concerned
about that then put in field turf and
put in a good drainage system it is a
safety hazard at a certain extent and it
yes it looked good it made for a
horrible game and and just when you
throw that feel that horrible muddy mess
of a field into a stadium that that
feels like it's been there for 120 years
not just 20 years fedex field
you get the goat horns and not even a
goat would go in there and eat that
grass
not right now it's muddy and wet you
know goats don't want to eat that kind
of grass no no but yeah i guess and even
if even if it wasn't i think the grass
is mainly green paint on dirt although
it was clearly it was clearly grass on
sunday although it was mud and it was
sloppy and it was amazing good job gotta
go on the drafts good
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports